today's topic skipping right skippy
where you live
ogden utah okay you live in the united
states
yes okay do you have running water yes
you have electricity you have food in
the fridge yeah okay you got nothing to
be depressed about there's children
right now
that don't even have clothes that don't
have food that don't have anything
only in the west do we have this this
notion that oh man it's so tough oh my
god i'm sad i don't know how i feel the
problem is this you're looking at what
you don't have instead of looking at
what you do have yes and you're making
excuses for your inadequacies
okay
all i hear is
[ __ ] whack bro and the thing is is
that
you've gotten away with doing this
for your entire adult life because no
one's told you the truth the stigma
surrounding depression and mental health
in general is terrible this whole idea
that depression is a
thing of the west
is a flat out lie
let me get let me tell you guys man
depression exists in third world
countries and in abundance as well
sometimes it's circumstantial to do with
other things but even for the wealthy
they're not always doing great
i can attest i just grow a bit tired of
hearing folks talk about depression
or mental health when they have no
knowledge about it nor are they licensed
to really talk about it i i for the life
of me don't understand why people would
go to
youtubers even us people come into our
lives sometimes like bro i'm hearing
voices and what [ __ ] go see a shrink go
see a doctor i'm not qualified and the
people's understanding of depression
isn't there it's not because you felt
pain that you understand what it's like
to feel chronic pain every day you don't
you don't know what it's like to have a
condition like that it's not because
you've been depressed that you
understand depression or chronic
depression right or clinical depression
you don't understand it necessarily
there's people who legitimately have
mental imbalances there's people whose
wires are crossed
there's people whose depression maybe
it's circumstantial there's some people
who
for whatever reason it's just there
and if you can't understand it for you
to sit there with anybody
and say
oh this is a thing in the west or you're
not depressed you don't know
this idea that depression is inherently
linked to what you have and what you
don't have you don't know what you're
talking about
depression is complicated and people who
have everything in life sometimes are
depressing people who have nothing in
life are sometimes depressed there's
such a negative stigma surrounding
mental health in these kinds of things
right especially the whole tough it up
man up all this other stuff it's like
guys sometimes you need to go seek help
you can work out as much as you want
sometimes you know you see a doctor we
we
especially from our communities right
the whole reason why people think
that a lot of these mental health issues
are just a western thing is because in
our countries we don't even acknowledge
any of these things we just say they're
crazy or we ignore it yeah and then
right i'm telling this right now when i
was living ethiopia yeah the amount of
mental health issues i saw from people
on the streets why because these people
just get abandoned yeah and they're
homeless no some of them are actually
just they have issues and the thing that
happened is that in this call in these
countries
here's the thing of the west thing in
the west uh no it's not
it's not and yeah but we don't hear
about it yeah because we're not
diagnosed and we're not we're not
helping them we'll just leave them be
and not only that
that's one of the reasons why living
expectancy is far
less in those countries because part of
it a lot a big part of it is because of
that because a lot of things are not
diagnosed and they just they just keep
on going you know i mean oh you just he
said oh you know you're causing you
because it's just a little bit different
they don't talk about [ __ ] like that
ever you know what i mean oh it's a
little bit it's either oh uh
a bad spirit it's either because the
person fell on his head or he just went
like that or it was sorcery often the
things that that happens and they they
don't link it to something that is
bigger and it's not diagnosed some
people with depression their brains are
literally different they can look at it
on a cat scan whatever it is that they
use and they can see the differences in
the brain reaction you guys have to
understand it's not something you do
with self-help it's not something you
undo with youtube for some of you you've
gone through a depressing period and you
came out of it for some people
depression is their whole lives from
when they are a child to when they are
going to die it never ends you know
someone said this they said depression
is like when your brain wants to die but
your body wants to live
guys you may never understand that even
though you may have struggled even
though your circumstances in life may be
far worse your brain just may be built
differently
so
on the outside
the reason why i don't like this is it
stops people from getting the treatment
that they need
the mere fact that people come to me
every day and they're like this is what
i'm dealing with this is my symptoms do
i look like a doctor have i ever
pretended to be one
however tried to diagnose folks and be
like your nurse i try to avoid doing
that or pathologizing things because i
don't have the aptitude support
understanding your limits is super
important so i look at you the viewer
and i said guys whatever you're dealing
with you're struggling with youtube may
have some great insight some great
information
fantastic but don't let anybody tell you
guys what's going on in your head other
than people who are actually trained for
it okay my final note if you're unhappy
with your life
getting women will not just inherently
make you happy
okay there's plenty of guys out there
who have the most amount of access to
women and are absolutely miserable
who take their lives
absolutely attractive people who for
whatever reason they wake up every day
and they want it to end
you don't just wake up one day and
become suicidal
there's a progression that happens
there's circumstances there's imbalances
that get you to that point understand
that
the
journey to getting a healthy balanced
life isn't a simple one and it's not a
one size fits all
okay
so i think that's kind of like the last
one i want
i'm not gonna comment on the people on
the the video uh what i'm gonna do is
this uh basically depression is
often a chemical imbalance in your brain
if i can sum it up
i summed up something that is very
difficult to sum up but it can be a
chemical imbalance in your brain it's
not something that just happened in the
west you are human being you can have
chemical imbalance in your brain
that's it's just that it's as simple as
that
it has nothing to do with running water
it has nothing to do with the possession
that you have
you can have a whole lamborghini sitting
in your driveway a big-ass car and
everything and stuff and you can one-off
yourself you know i mean by that
definition all the stars that themselves
are just you know [ __ ] or whatever
they have nothing to complain about we
don't know that there's chemical
imbalances and things that people are
dealing with and that's why we can't
just summarize it to the things that we
have it's not that
yes
i agree that money doesn't buy happiness
but it does make [ __ ] easier
but it doesn't mean that [ __ ] cannot
happen and chemical imbalance and
depression cannot happen
it's much more complex and difficult
than that
it really sounds like
it makes it sounds like people that are
depressed no people that are suffering
from depression are really just
complaining
that's not what it is
it's not just someone complaining
someone it's not oh he's not happy it's
not
it's deeper than that
so
yeah
it's making huh ten percent of all don't
suffer from it yeah it's a uh it's it's
it's a shortcut it's a it's a very big
shortcut but at the end of the day it's
not the first time that that's happened
but i'm not gonna comment on that
anymore all all that to say
it's complicated
don't sum it up to that it's it's yeah
there's people who are ultra successful
who achieve everything in life and still
feel that
for whatever reason okay and the way
people talk about depression a lot of
stuff is the way people used to talk
about ptsd
oh my god i literally have pity asd from
this cockroach i saw [ __ ] no
no
no not even that it's like they didn't
think it was a real thing no not that or
they didn't treat it like it or they
didn't address it as such so absolutely
not i'm gonna finish with this i do a
lot of these things on my instagram
um
kingpiece to petty i ask people to ask
me questions and stuff like that and
often it's like yo i have this i have
data and the first thing i do is i seek
professional help
oh i'm not that guy
oh baby what should i do if i feel like
i'm gonna kill myself
seek professional help
i am not 4-1-1 i am not 9-1-1 i am not
that guy
i am not go see it that's the first
thing i'm going to say the last thing
i'm going to say is this no depression
is
is equal
if you went through yours doesn't mean
that other people it's not the same as
other people
and also nobody is safe
nobody is safe you can go through your
whole life without depression good on
you but you're not safe
it can't happen to anybody
ptsd is a perfect example that you could
be a well-adjusted person and go through
a traumatic experience and never be the
same again yeah can't close doors you
hear any loud noises you freak out yeah
that happens those are real issues
nobody's safe anything else you want to
say no all right leave your comments
below on what you guys think in regards
to the whole discussion surrounding
depression and um yeah do you guys
really feel like it's more a matter of
your choices or is it a matter of
circumstances
[Music]
is
[Applause]
i